during the installation of a network
understanding the pattern and
configuration of a network device and
system is very important
to solve such problems network topology
is used
which explains the network configuration
network connection and data exchange
hi guys i'm weber kandalwal and i
welcome you all to yet another exciting
video by simply learn but before we
begin if you love watching tech videos
then subscribe to our channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
from us let's take a look at today's
agenda
for the first step we will look into
what is network topology all about
then we will continue with why to apply
this network concept
and then we will look into different
types of network topologies in detail
then we will choose which network
topologies we should use
then let's begin with the first heading
what is network topology
it is referred to as an arrangement of
multiple systems and network devices
interconnected to each other
through a physical medium or logical
channel
the term network topology is combination
of two individual network concept
first is the network part which
represents the devices or systems that
are also known as nodes
which is connected and how to change the
data within the network
then the other part is topology which
represents the connection medium between
different network devices and governs
the data flow between them
moving on let's talk about why do we
apply the concept of network topology
for the first point it allows the users
to understand the overall model of the
network along with the number of devices
installed and their positions in the
network which provide ease of
installation of security measures and
network and helps in case of
troubleshooting cases
then for the next reason applying
network topology helps the user to
understand the communication
relationship among the different devices
and through a connection medium
this in turn helps the network
professionals to set up an optimal
network unit for the user
next in the list we have different types
of topologies used in networking
first is
the bus topology
then we have ring topology then star
topology then tree topology and in the
end mesh topology but to understand the
concept of topology let's start by
point-to-point topology this is simpler
form of topology connection which
consists of two nodes connected through
a connection medium like a network cable
the nodes at the two ends of the cable
shares data information between them
where the data sharing part represents
the network and the cable connection is
the topology part
with this we have understanding of
network topology then let's begin with
complex types of tech connections
first is the bus topology in this
topology the connection channel is a
single cable known as the network
backbone through which all the other
nodes are connected to
in this network setting the data packets
sent by the nodes are provided with the
receiver address to avoid transmission
errors
the data in this topology can travel
from any end point where
they are termed as terminate points
advantages of bus topology it is easy to
set up due to the simple configuration
settings
this setting is also cost effective as
it requires only a network cable for the
connection
in the case of kreshnot the whole
network remains unaffected as it does
not have any direct connection to the
other node
let's take a look at disadvantages of
bus topology
in case of troubleshooting we require
the use of special equipment to detect
the fault in the network in the case of
multiple data transmission the packet
collision is the frequent occurrence
damaging the transmitted message data
due to the unavailability of network
devices such as switches repeaters etc
the loss of data over long distances
communication is quite high then ring
topology as the name suggests the node
in the network are connected in a
circular pattern similar to a ring
the data transmitted in this connection
is always in the clockwise direction the
topology does not have any termination
point due to its ring structure the
method of data transmission is used is
known as token passing which involves
sending a token along with the data
packet to which each of the node matches
to identify the destination node using
the destination address in the token
next advantages of ring topology the
crash node can be easily removed from
the network
the configuration settings are not
complex for setup and materials are
easily accessible
the cost of installation is low as no
extra network device are required to the
connection
moving on we have disadvantages of ring
topology
in the case of a node crash the whole
system is affected and is non accessible
due to the direct connection of each
node
the transfer of data is low due to the
token passing method in the network
difficulty in the troubleshooting fault
in the connection leads to the trash of
the whole network now let's talk about
star topology in this topology the
networks are connected to each other
through the central hub which can be a
computer or a server the central unit in
the connection is also known as the
server and the nodes are known as the
clients any connection between the node
has to be through the server and is one
of the most popular topology connection
next advantages of star topology in case
of a node crash the network as a whole
remains unaffected as each node is
connected to the server of a connection
the hardware requirements are easily
available and of low cost
troubleshooting is easy
through the use of central hub to
identify the faulty node
in case of a server failure the whole
network is shut down as all nodes are
interconnected through the server
the connection configuration is complex
due to the pattern of the typology next
up free topology
this topology is a combination of tar
and bus topology the node connection in
the topology follows hierarchal pattern
with the topmost node as the root and
the branching node as the child node the
sharing of data is from the root node to
the child node pattern
next up advantages of tree installation
of a new network group is easy due to
the root child configuration of the
network
in case of a node fault or trash the
whole network is not affected by the
error this makes it easier to
troubleshoot the issue
next up disadvantages in case of a
server crash in any of the star
connection groups the whole network is
affected
due to the complex setting of the
topology installing security points is
difficult in the network
configuring and troubleshooting internal
issues is quite complex due to this
topology next up mesh topology
as the name suggests this topology is a
connection of interconnected system
connected to each other in no particular
order
no installation of network devices such
as switch or hubs this topology pattern
can be divided into two forms
first is full match topology in this
connection all the nodes are connected
to each other in the network then we
have partial mesh topology where all of
the nodes are connected to each other
available in the network let's talk
about the advantages of mesh topology in
case of node damage the whole network
does not suffer from the fault due to
the interconnected patterns of the
connection the transmission of data is
very high in the network
next up disadvantages
the cost of installation is high due to
the requirement of multiple cables and
nodes for the network to function
efficiently
the management of the network becomes
complex due to the large number of
interconnections in the network due to
the absence of repeater or a switch the
data signal loss during the transmission
is very high now let's take a look at
how to choose best topology for a
network configuration first of course
the installation cost is one of the
biggest factors that affects the type of
topology configuration we choose from
our network as the cost of installing
cables routers switches and other
network connections is slow then we have
easy installation installing the
hardware devices efficiently and
precisely is also one of the factors
that affect our choice of network
topology moving on we have flexibility
the ability of the topology to include
new network nodes after installation and
ease of troubleshooting refers to the
flexibility of topology in the hand we
have reliable security it is important
that the topology installed allows us to
introduce proper security points in the
network and leading the fewer cash cases
by referring the above factors we can
decide the best topology for our network
with this we have reached the end of the
video if you have any question regarding
the topic you can ask them in the
comment section below thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simply lunch
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here